[Music]
a severe health crisis in the latin
american country
one might least have expected one
chilean is dying from covet 19
every 15 minutes and critical care units
are overflowing
dr sebastiano garte runs the icu at
santiago's indiesa clinic
and takes us to see for ourselves that
every bed is occupied
even though the number of critical care
units nearly doubled this week
and this happened issue people over 17
most of whom have already been
vaccinated have almost disappeared from
our emergency rooms
now we have younger patients but some
gravely ill
chile's second wave is turning out to be
far more aggressive than the first
even though more than 33 percent of the
population has received one or both
jabs these people are among the tens of
thousands of chileans who are queueing
at this hour for their coronavirus
vaccine and while chile is a world
leader in terms of the percentage of the
population that has already been
inoculated
health officials warn it will not make
much difference
at least not for some time
in order for herd immunity to be
effective eighty percent of chileans
must be fully vaccinated
and that won't happen for another three
months
our duty is to make the vaccine
available to everyone
free of charge and to convince you all
that it's effective
and safe back at the hospital
doctors and nurses concede they're
exhausted
30 percent of staff are a medical leave
from illness or stress
and they're more difficult to replace
than a bed or respiratory
we caught our breath between the first
and second wave but the patient load
never dropped enough to really let us
recover
so here we are practically living here
nurse matthias hernandez hasn't been
able to travel home
for nearly a year
it's very stressful the patients are in
a critical condition
there's no time to rest because the
number of patients multiply faster than
we do
but we do all we can while chileans
suffering from pandemic burnout have
clearly let down their guard
dr ugarte is one of many who questions
the government's overall pandemic
strategy
the strategy was not to suppress the
pandemic but to contain it
a delicate balance in which flexibility
and easing restrictions have led to
thousands of new patients despite the
inoculation
a bitter lesson for a country that
thought it was out of the woods
and a wake-up call for others who are
counting on vaccines
to be the magic cure lucia newman al
jazeera
santiago